when you sweat a lot in times of peace
you bleed less in times of war
that way whenever you do the first habit
you're automatically gonna do the second
happen I called these trigger habits you
know there's a difference between
looking at something and seeing it
really seeing it there's difference me
hearing something and really listening
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message live in the now
over to yoga or Gopal das also if you
want to know what Gore Gopal das and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below it's easy to make
a buck very hard to make a difference I
[Music]
think when we talk about being in the
present we don't have to start getting
into the present when the pressure is
high we need to start practicing being
in the present when the pressure is low
there's a very nice quote that I read
once in one of the barracks of the
Indian Army which said when you sweat a
lot in times of peace you bleed less in
times of war IPL for instance cricket
now when the match is on the world
tournaments on the the competition stuff
is you right there and under the spot
which means the pressure is high and you
need to be focused you need to be
present you can only do it effectively
when you learn to be present in the
smaller things of life I often tell
people that when we talk about being
present one thing that we should start
practicing is start being physically
present like I give the example I have a
glass of juice here you know when I'm
this mango juice why do I need to watch
television why do I have to keep
checking messages on my phone what I'm
doing by looking at the television and
why looking at the phone is being
distracted from drinking the juice so
why I'm drinking the juice
let me just drink the juice what's
happening is I'm being present
physically present now it's not so much
about just being drinking the juice but
about cultivating the attitude behind
drinking the juice of being present in
what I'm doing I also tell people beyond
being physically present we need to also
be emotionally present very often you
see people today are talking to each
other chatting with each other they're
looking around here and there
they're scrolling on their phones
they're looking at their messages
descending whatsapp messages what
they're doing is they're completely
getting distracted and not learning to
live in the now being emotionally
present means when I'm talking to you
for instance I am with you I'm not
looking at this plant behind me I'm not
looking at the camera here I'm not
looking at the cup of juice I am looking
at you I'm soaking in every single word
as you speak that's not just about
speaking it's about cultivating the
attitude of being present the best way
to build a new habit is to tie it to an
existing habit that you are currently
consistently doing find something that
you are consistently doing on a regular
basis and then tie your new habit to
that existing one that way whenever you
do the first habit you're automatically
gonna do the second happen I call these
trigger habits one existing habit
triggers the second habit so that it
happens automatically when you don't
build trigger habits you're less likely
to follow through you're likely to
forget because it's just not a part of
your daily routine because you had an
intention to build a habit and you have
a deep down sincere desire to build that
habit you really want it to happen but
you just forget and life gets in the way
and you get back into your day to day
grind and you forget to do the thing and
then if you forget to do that
habet consistently enough if a couple
days go by pretty soon you forgot that
you even had the intention to build that
habit so you build the trigger habit you
tie the habit that you want to build
into a current habit that you are
consistently doing right
having trigger habits also helps you
with one of the things that is most
difficult about building new habits
which is sticking with it after a
certain amount of time after you've
already built up the motivation and the
desire and the inspiration to do it when
now that motivation goes away it's hard
to stick with that new habit but if
you're tying it to a trigger habit if
you're tying to something that you're
already consistently doing then as long
as you keep doing that first habit
you're gonna keep on sticking with that
second habit as well so as an example if
you wanted to stay present and the juice
was gonna be your example of what Gore
Gopal das just did if you drink juice
every day then you tie that habit when I
drink juice I think about being
president than now when I drink juice I
think about being present in and out
when I drink juice I think about being
present in there now I might even get
cups let's say be present being the now
so there's a reminder and always use
that cup make sure you wash it in
between always use that cup and fill it
with juice and when you're drinking your
juice
it's your reminder so that becomes the
trigger habit for the new habit that
you're trying to build one of the habits
that I wanted to build was when I was on
my cellphone not to be hunched over and
get neck pains and get back pains and
have this really bad posture every time
I went on my cellphone I found that I
was constantly doing that I'd be fine
when I'm standing up at home when I'm at
my office because I I'm on the stand-up
desk I'm on a rebounder I can bounce
around but I found as soon as I got to
my cell phone my posture would
self-destruct and I'd end up having a
lot of back and neck pain so I wanted to
build a habit on top of the trigger
habit so the trigger habit was picking
up my phone I pick up my phone multiple
times per day right I pick up my phone
to check my Instagram dm's I check out
my YouTube comments to answer email on
down times I'm picking up my phone a lot
so that's the trigger habit the trigger
habit is picking up the phone I wanted
to build a new habit of fixing my
posture every time I picked up my phone
so how did I do that
here's what I did I changed my cell
phone background to the proper posture
that you're supposed to have when you're
using your cell phone and they made it a
picture of Nina so that I'd also smile
every time I see
so instead of looking at my phone down
here being hunched over I'm reminded to
keep my phone up at eye level so that I
would save my neck and my back now when
I first did this I actually had a
picture of a different woman who was
demoing this and I put that as my
cellphone background and I thought Nina
would not be happy with me looking at
another woman every time I picked up my
cellphone so I said Nina I need you to
pose like this go like this with your
cellphone and smile and that's gonna be
my new background for my cell phone so
the habit I wanted to build was having
better posture the trigger habit was
going to be picking up my cell phone as
long as I pick up my cell phone that
pictures gonna be there and it's gonna
be a reminder for me to check my posture
every single time so that's the power of
trigger habits when you do it properly
you don't have to think about being
motivated and being inspired and
thinking about doing the habit that's
the problem you're trying to build a new
habit but you forget to do it because it
requires you thinking about doing it and
so if you can tie it to an existing
habit then as long as you're
consistently doing that first trigger
habit then you will continue to do the
second habit that you want to build as
well now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is one habit that you want
to change and then what is the trigger
habit that will help you stay consistent
and cause that change you're gonna link
them together I want to know what that
is for you leave in the comments below
let's say everyone uses a search engine
like Google every single day but a lot
of people they use it ten times a day if
I ask them are you willing to bet your
life you know what colors the letters
are because that's that's an observation
you know there's a difference between
looking at something and seeing it
really seeing it there's difference
between hearing something and really
listening
you know like leaders like for example I
had this whole escapade with the x-men
which was insane but I had to leave the
the set because there I had to go to a
charity event and one of the people that
I think leaders the independent of your
political bent who has an incredible
memory as President Clinton every single
time I've met President Clinton he's
remembered my name know what he does and
how many people does he's very to them
yes you how many people does Clinton
meet on a regular basis right and so
that's a leadership skill though right
and so FDR was incredible with names
also he would walk around the White
House and point people out and say hi to
them say saying hi to their spouse and
using by name I mean that's cuz I think
about the sweetest sound in person's
ears right America's their name all
right and said so anyway I asked him
what's memory tricky uses he uses no
memory tricks at all and he tells me
this you know this is amazing don't
worry yes and so he tells me this
incredible story about how he knows his
grandfather you know in Arkansas but to
get all the kids around tell stories to
them but then he would quiz them they
would really need to listen to be
present and it's funny because I noticed
that like he's Bill Clinton is Anna
Carla stuff worried how you feel
politically incredible communicator yeah
incredible charisma incredible connector
right
and he also this memory I find he's this
incredible presence this powerful
presence but I find that his powerful
presence and his memory comes from being
powerfully present his powerful presence
comes from being powerfully present and
here's the thing when people are
networking because I know a lot of
people there's they're entrepreneurs or
social entrepreneurs and littles either
going out there meeting people because
really it's it's what you know and it's
who you know but that's all memory what
you know claw people go to seminar two
days later they'll forget
everything right 80% there's a big
forgetting curve but also who you know
and who knows you right but what are the
challenges is they'll be networking and
how many time do you find yourself
talking to somebody and then looking
over their shoulder yeah I hate when
people to thank you that it's like
annoying cuz you're distracting yourself
at all times more if you're not just
dragging yourself externally you're like
talking to yourself what am I gonna say
Mary exactly so the people aren't even
listening this is so key when people are
communicating most of the times you find
that they're not even really listening
what they are is they're thinking about
how they're gonna respond yeah you know
and if you look at the word listen and
you scramble the letters it becomes the
word silent no yeah I think that in
order for us to truly change we have to
get beyond ourselves and that is one of
the arts of transformation and at the
moment we are completely in the present
moment we cannot be running a program it
turns out coincidentally when we're
truly in the present moment all
possibilities in the quantum field
exists in the eternal now so when we're
truly present and we take our attention
off our body off of people in our lives
off of things off of places and even
time that's the moment as I said today
we become pure consciousness that's the
moment now we are no longer playing by
the laws of Newtonian physics that's the
moment we no longer have our attention
invested in this three-dimensional
reality and where we place our attention
is where we place our energy so then the
moment we become nobody no one no thing
no we're in no time
that's the moment we get beyond
ourselves it is that act of being in the
present moment that allows us to see new
possibilities that we could never see
from the place where we are stuck in our
own programs and personality the act of
doing that as Bruce said is a skill and
it requires feedback and feedback
happens in a couple ways
one way you get feedback is to begin to
measure the changes you see in your life
another way is that you feel differently
another way is that the voice in your
head goes away that's telling you you
can it's too hard you'll never change
this process if it was easy everybody
would be doing it and yet we are
piercing a veil where people are waking
up and they're beginning to take their
power back we already innately know how
to do this all we have to do is keep
practicing until we start seeing those
wonderful wonderful feedback mechanisms
happening in our life the moment you
start seeing those changes taking place
in your life you are going to pay
attention to what you did to cause it
and the moment you pay attention to the
cause of that action you're no longer
thinking that it's something out there
that did it you're beginning to realize
it's what you did inside of you to
produce it that's when we get to take
our power back if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple so it would be like
a little beacon if you want more Guru
Gopal das check out the five pieces of
life-changing advice from him video the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there some people are so
poor so poor that all they have is money
[Music]